do you remember the moment of this
discovery of Mazur well see I had been
working very hard thinking of different
ways of some ways of producing short
ways and I'd even been made a chairman
of a department for the chairman of a
committee rather for the country to try
to examine how to out of reduce
shortwaves
now committee travelled around and
looked at what people were trying to do
and so on
we just didn't come up with any good
ideas so we would have our last meeting
in Washington DC and just before that
last meeting I woke up early in the
morning we thought I was worried about
we hadn't been able to do anything I
went out I sat in the park is a
beautiful day and the flowers were
blooming under sunny and I sat on the
bench and I why haven't we been able to
do this and I went through all the
possibilities we had thought of you see
and I had thought of things I had tried
and this didn't work and this didn't
work very well why can't we do it now
well I thought you know if we could get
radiation from molecules molecules can
produces very short wavelengths but how
can do that
oh wait a minute wait a minute I thought
hey this is the way to do it
oh yes we can do it from molecules we
get molecules in a right kind of state
and that can happen and it was exciting
it was exciting and I went back to my
hotel room and I was in the same hotel
room with office although who was a
postdoc with me at the time I told him
that he said oh well you know that
sounds sound all right so then I went
back to Columbia and after a little
while I got a student to work on it and
we've actually made it work